There are a lot of accounts out there that are perfectly curated...
...and don't reflect or seem connected in any way to reality.
Nobody is perpetually happy, for the record, okay?
So if somebody seems like that on social media,...
...then maybe they're not telling the full truth.
I even unfollowed GaryVee, not because I don't like his message,...
...because I think what he is all about is amazing,...
...and I just love what he talks about on social media and how he talks about it.
But the truth is that, after a while,...
...it just became a series of reminders and you know, I got it.
I no longer needed these reminders.
I'm sure he would approve of this decision.
He's even said on social media that he's perfectly okay with you unfollowing him...
...to go and pursue meaning in life.
I really do believe there's a lot of quality out there.
You just have to kind of dig a little bit and get through the BS to get there.